[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online Athena and I mean Kim Kardashian
enjoyed some quality time with her
daughter North who had fun dressing up
as the Tooth Fairy come card to pal cuz
you're the tooth fairy
yeah in other cute baby news pink shared
this sweet snap cuddled up with her son
Jameson
meanwhile several stars have been in
celebration mode here's Madonna at a
Purim party in full costume as Beauty
and the Beast we wanted to meet us
before the party just to get a feel of
what we want Jersey Shore star Sammi
Sweetheart Giancola
turned up for her 30th birthday
alongside some of her former co-stars
including Nicole Snooki Polizzi Jenni
JWoww Farley Deena Cortese E and Vinny
Guadagnino why leave America's Got town
it seems like a dream job why leave that
job because it's a job uh and and people
I'm not defined by a job America's Got
Talent has found their new host in Tyra
Banks the NBC competition show shared
the news to Instagram on Sunday for
years people have been asking me to quit
drugs and get sober and now that I have
everyone thinks I'm unfunny and boring
SNL star Pete Davidson recently revealed
he's sober and on Saturday show he got
real about the perks of his healthier
lifestyle at least they have dreams now
and I've started waking up with boners
again
you